this video right here i'm going to go
through the fundamental essentials that
you need to understand to create a 3d
architectural diagram i'm going to be
going through archicad twin motion
photoshop and illustrator to create this
one simple diagram it's going to be an
overarching overall tutorial on all four
programs to make sure you're able to do
this with your very own project
what's going on guys my name's david
thomas welcome back to the channel if
you're new here firstly thank you so
much for joining me on this channel we
talk about architecture and technology
if that's something that interests you
make sure you smash that subscribe
button to tune in to any future video
today we're talking about creating
architectural 3d diagrams now you may
have seen these on instagram on tiktok
or somewhere potentially in your studio
where you've seen somebody do it better
today i'm going to show you the
fundamental basics of how you can master
3d architectural diagrams and showcase
your skills in whatever project comes
next now in this video i'm assuming that
you already have an architectural model
built up in archicad that you can use
for this tutorial i'm not going to be
going through archicad so much in this
video i have done plenty of archicad
tutorials so feel free to tune into
those if you're looking for an archicad
tutorial today we're taking it to that
next level there's no messing around
today so let's turn around to these two
screens behind me and get on with the
tutorial so the archicad model that i
have here open in front of me will be
the fundamental basics of what we're
talking about today this archicad model
i actually created a tutorial on youtube
so if you want to go and check it out
i'll leave a link down below so you can
go back and follow it the tutorial for
this one was predominantly focusing on
this cladding system here and the actual
overall design of the building as well
so what is so unique about this cladding
is it actually wraps all the way around
same wall same roof system with
completely hidden secret gutter along
the main pitch of the roof today we're
not focusing on the architecture or the
arcade side we're focusing on creating a
3d architectural diagram by using the
fundamental basics of this building
block i want you to be able to go home
and apply this basically to any project
that you're working on and create 3d
architectural diagrams specific for your
project now before we take it into twin
motion we want to make sure that our
mesh is completely off that is critical
to this and saves so so much time now to
transition this into twin motion we can
either go file save as a twin motion
file or if you've installed a plugin
simply twin motion direct link let's
call this a brand new project new
project okay let it synchronize as you
can see that's opened up relatively
quickly in twin motion and our settings
are half decent straight out of twin
motion which is why i like using the
system
what we are going to do is just
manipulate a couple of these settings to
create this as best as we can in an
actual visualization so let's start by
going materials wood and i'm going to
drag this onto the decking here so we
have a nice dark timber deck
then i'm going to go back to my metal
change my brushed aluminium to the whole
house adjust the color to something a
little bit darker not too dark so we can
still see the materiality and the
textures somewhere of a dark gun metal
grey finally i'm going to come across
into my glass and go reflective glass so
we can see the reflection of basically
nothing because we are not
really reflecting too much i'm going to
do is change the foundational base of
this model i'm simply just going to go
into ground
nature and change that to grass too so
we have some sort of natural reflection
on the whole project i'm going to scale
that up a little bit too much so it
because we're going to be cutting it out
so it isn't really required to be
realistic and i'm also going to increase
the height of it so we just start to
trim into our decking
next we're going to come across to our
settings and our location because i am
in perth western australia i'm going to
type in perth use my current location
and change this to how i best see fit so
if we want to actually make this a
little bit nicer i'm just going to
adjust the north point more so than
anything
so adjusting it to a really good
location so we can see all of our
details i'm going to be focusing on
something like an axonometric here which
means i'm going to be wanting a north
point that showcases our shadows
showcases how the building works and
makes it look really really nice the
best for me i believe is actually
pointing backwards it gives us some
depth it gives us some perception and we
are able to see most of our projects
next we're going to come into our
background change the city to absolutely
nothing because we don't really care
about the background at all
and then we're going to go into media
image click our first image
and enter into the more options this is
where it's critically important to get
those diagrams looking really really
nice we're going to come into our camera
settings and drag that field of view
all the way to the base
pressing w s a d we're going to fly out
zoom out and
come up into our isometric view
so as you can see now we've positioned
this model central to our image and
we've created an isometric view which
gives us the best diagrammatic view
possible in my personal opinion at least
next i'm going to come back into my
image one and my image and then refresh
my settings entirely so i don't have to
see what i was saying before i'm going
to try center that a little bit more and
zoom in a little bit more so i see
pretty much as much of my building as i
possibly can
without going overboard so i think
now that corners in that corner is in
the frame i'm going to refresh that so
we have the clearest image of our
project possible
now before we leave this image and
before we leave twin motion i do want to
throw in a couple people into this space
so we actually get
something interesting happening in the
actual diagram so i'll throw a little
man here i'll throw a lady as well
somewhere next to him orientate so they
look like they're talking maybe also
some sort of animal maybe a little puppy
dog next to them looks like they're
having a very pleasant conversation and
then finally i might also introduce one
small tree in the background of this
image now because i have all of this
grass and i want to cut that out that
tree is not going to stand out at all
and it's going to be a nightmare to cut
out in photoshop so what i'm going to go
is go into my leaf tint and simply drag
that down to a much much darker green
almost black that way when we actually
have to cut it out in photoshop we can
let photoshop do most the work for us
what might also be nice is potentially a
small little table and chairs on the
outside so let's just go home living
room tables find a small little outdoor
setting that will
provide a small pop of color put it in
the shadows so it doesn't overly reflect
and look too powerful in the image
and that's pretty much all i need to do
now before we export this image one
fundamental basic that you want to keep
in mind is you want to export this to
the highest possible settings your
computer can handle so if we go into
image one more come across the format
and change this here from full hd to at
least 4k
you can bump that up to 8k 16k whatever
your computer can handle for the
purposes of this i'm simply just going
to showcase 4k we're going to come to
export down the bottom export click on
the image we want and select that
directly exporting to our desktop
now i'm quickly going to put this in to
lightroom so we can adjust those colors
make them look vibrant make them pop
make them look fantastic like we've
exported it out of a really high-end
rendering software and then we're gonna
take it into photoshop i'm gonna let
this export i'll see you in about two
seconds but for me it's probably going
to be about two minutes now before we go
on to the next steps i just wanted to
quickly point out the links down below
there are a couple incredible digital
downloads and assets for you guys
including construction checklists and
archicad title blocks there is also a
phenomenal discord chat which is
completely free to join for all
architects architecture students or
anybody in the profession so far it is
growing phenomenally well and everybody
in that group is helping each other out
constant questions are being asked and
people are able to resolve them so i'm
really really happy with how that little
discord chat is growing and how
everybody is interacting in it if you
want a copy of any of the tutorial files
that i make on youtube there is a
patreon link down below where you can
subscribe as a patreon legend level
member and gain access to all the files
through the discord chat if any of those
interest you make sure you check out the
links down below and don't forget to hit
the like button and the subscribe button
to help this video with the youtube
algorithm so i can make sure i keep
helping people just like you better
themselves as architects designers or
anything in between all right so i've
dragged that 4k image that i've exported
out of twin motion directly into
lightroom so we can start messing with
these settings if we come across to our
develop tab up the top we can see we
have a number of different settings here
on the side now you can do it the slow
way and go through and individually
adjust everything or personally i've
created a series of twin motion presets
that are available in the digital
downloads link below that you can
quickly download and just apply those
filters
just as you see fit so if we scroll
through these i have all the different
seasons to be able to give you a
different look for what you might be
looking for and of course i have an
internal and an external because twin
motion changes the colors so so much so
if we look at the autumn the spring the
summer and the winter different presets
personally i think the winter preset
external is my absolute favorite for
this one and all i'm going to do is just
adjust the shadows that little bit so so
we can see our furniture in the shade
next all i have to do is right click
scroll up to edit in adobe photoshop
2021
you're going to get this message pop up
here edit with a copy of lightroom
adjustments and you just hit edit it'll
automatically import that into photoshop
so now we have photoshop open what we're
going to do is simply come across here
to our polygonal lasso tool if you don't
see this pluto lasso tool click and hold
on that third icon down to come to your
polygonal lasso tool what we're going to
do now is simply go around this building
clicking dragging and cutting out all
the shapes we're probably going to click
quickly around that tree and then let
photoshop do the rest so by holding alt
on your keyboard and scrolling on your
keyboard you can zoom in as much as you
need to start actually cutting out so by
clicking once dragging all the way up
and then clicking on our shadows i do
want to keep them personally i think it
will make this image look so so much
better we're going to be able to cut
this entire building out now i'm going
to go through and click all the way
around this image show you what i've
selected
so you don't have to watch me click a
million times and be back in two seconds
okay so what i've done now is gone
around selected all of my shadows
selected the building cropped around
this tree quickly and selected the main
elements of our building next i'm going
to click ctrl shift and i to invert that
selection and tap the delete button
all of a sudden very quickly we've
created a png with the background cut
out by pressing ctrl d i'm going to
deselect everything
zoom in to this tree
and then i'm going to press my w key or
the icon just below to select my magic
wand again like before if you don't get
the magic wand click and hold and you
will have a variety of different
selections next i'm going to increase my
tolerance to about 50 and start clicking
a few sections of this grass here
then i'm going to reduce my tolerance
down to 1 go select
similar
and press the delete button
next we're going to go file save as save
that to our desktop we're just going to
simply save that save a copy
as probably a png because we don't want
to see that background and we're going
to go diagram
raw
so we know what we're looking for i'm
going to keep it large so we have a lot
of that data click ok with that image
open in illustrator we can start
adjusting and creating our actual
diagrammatic details so first of all i'm
going to come into the layer setting i'm
going to center this image
perfectly in the center of that page
lock it so we can't touch that anymore
and start a new layer
this is going to be our shadows
and next is going to be our diagrams
so let's start working on our shadow
details if we close that layers panel
select p for our pen tool
and zoom in to our shadows what i'm
going to simply do is actually copy
the sun that we created and create a
very nice dark
rich diagrammatic shadow so there i've
gone around i've traced that shadow
created it nice black and rich it's
probably too black for this image
because most of that image is quite dark
so i might lift it to about 50 percent
and create a
50
dark gray shadow that we can utilize
next i'm going to come back into my
layer setting lock those shadows because
that's the only shadows we're working
with go into my diagrams and start
messing around with what is the
fundamental principles of this
architectural 3d diagram so again we
want to utilize that pen tool we want to
work on a number of different colors so
let's start with yellow for the sun and
swap it around so we have our stroke in
this instance you'll see that the sun
path will do something along these lines
here
so if i finish my diagram like that you
can see that line is way way way too
thin let's adjust that to about 20.
again it didn't take into account what i
was saying before with those details so
we're going to keep adjusting that until
we're happy
i think 30 points is very nice we have
that sun sweeping line across then i'm
simply just going to drag it a little
bit away from our actual image next i'm
going to go ahead and create a very
simple sun by using the star tool and
filling that entirely in yellow rotating
it ever so slightly and placing it at
the end of our little stroke
so now we see our sunrise our sunset
path we see that path
next we're going to hit that p button
again change our
colors across to a stroke let's go to
green for this instance actually let's
go to blue because we're going to
represent the ventilation of this
building and how it works test out what
this might look like and just create a
little bit of a curvy line there it's
very again very very thin we're going to
make that about 20 points so we can see
it again i want to make it
nice and
flowy very similar to the sun path next
what we might be taking into
consideration is the actual materiality
of the fundamentals of this project so
if we click p again let's go to a nice
black texture we're going to leave it as
a very simple thin line
and let's start by zooming into this
roof over here so if i zoom in let's say
i click on that roof start creating a
curved line and
extending that out clicking on that line
once more going to our stroke and
changing our arrow head well not that
one changing this arrow head i still
don't like how thick that line is let's
change that to about a two
and reduce that back to a hundred
percent so we have a nice thin line now
we have our first arrowhead which is
going to explain the materiality we're
going to create a few more here
so we can continue to explain what this
project is about
finally we just want to go across to our
text tool start typing in what these
elements actually are so for example
this is max line
cladding
it is way too small let's bump that up
to about 40 points so it can actually be
seen especially if you're point posting
this on instagram
probably a little bit too big let's go
back to 30 points just adjust this to
whatever size you think works really
really well for you and i'm just going
to repeat that for a couple other
elements if you wanted to make it even
cooler and make it stand out even more
if you haven't already noticed i'm a big
fan of black so what we do is change all
our black
and invert that image entirely so it
stands out on this beautiful black
presentation board overall there's
everything you need to know from arcade
twin motion into lightroom then to
photoshop and illustrator five programs
absolutely essential to any architect
creating good 3d diagrams that's all for
me today guys thank you so much for
watching i hope you enjoyed the video i
hope you learned something new that you
hadn't known before if you did make sure
you smash that subscribe button down
below and just for me make sure you hit
that like button believe it or not the
like button in conjunction with maybe a
cheeky little comment down below will
help this video so much with the
algorithm the algorithm is ever changing
but we're slowly making sure that these
videos get seen by more and more people
every single time i post so i truly
appreciate all of you guys who have
smashed the like button and the
subscribe button in all of my videos and
like always i'll see you next monday